there's a phrase associated with NASA
failure is not an option but there's
another one in Innovation that is fail
fast and fail often it's a world of both
iris is the first American robot on the
moon it is the first Universe built it
is the first student-led the first for
proving this capability of small Rovers
this is like teaching a baby to walk and
before it gets to that million critical
steps on another planet there'll be tens
of millions here on Earth
my name is red Whitaker I'm a professor
of Robotics this is my 50th year at
Carnegie Mellon
I created the iris idea and from that
produced the very first course that
engaged and enrolled students and
fostered it to and through where we are
right now I can't do that uh looks like
we're taking the rough average of our
estimates play the same student
recommend that like backward 15. right
acrossing permission to move backwards
15 centimeters is five centimeters per
second iris is a shoebox on Wheels it is
going to the Moon to prove that small is
capable iris is two kilograms has very
bottle cap wheel design made out of
carbon fiber very very small compared to
typical SUV sized Rovers
technology that has built Iris over the
years has really stemmed from various
projects that date back to the 80s when
red really became interested in space
Robotics and lunar robotics I formulated
this notion of developing thinking
machines at work in the world and in
Worlds Beyond never change one word of
it and never ran out of anything great
to do the one that's left on the
checklist is
robots to world's Beyond
[Music]
it takes a few wealthy individuals who
are willing to invest their own time and
money and who are excited about space to
start this social movement it's
generating the imagination it's really
bringing the excitement back into space
it's opening doors and opportunities
that really weren't here before
one of the biggest things about this
project is that it's not a government
entity because it's a student project
reaching out to the community is such a
huge part of this Venture and so having
the students do a crowdfunding campaign
learning how that process works it's
something that is a really unique
opportunity to bring everybody in and
show that anybody can make it to the
Moon it can be a group of students with
a dream and that one unified Vision
these students can do it
my grand dream for the mission
is that Iris will drive one meter
once it gets to the Moon
tell us his flight on Ops do you copy
copy NSS on the far side
Iris requests permission to deploy from
the Lander the mission success comes
from the Rover deploying driving taking
a picture and sending a picture back to
Earth even if things go wrong after that
it can do the basics and it shows that
in future iterations it's possible so
many thousands of things have to be
right
to get that far
and of course anything that goes wrong
can be a fatal glitch
every rover mission has two Landings
there's one where the Lander makes it to
the Moon
and the second more important one is
where the Rover gets to the surface all
of the other Rovers have had big ramps
they could roll down
or mechanisms that would place them on
the surface or for Mars along cable that
lowers them right to the surface this is
the very first that will drop deploy
when it's in the moon it's released and
it floats
to the surface our hope is that it lands
on level easy Terrain
other challenges are the customary ones
from space vacuum heat cold radiation
violent shaking success is never
forgotten and anything beyond a little
bit of driving on the moon is all bonus
we are a payload on astrobotics
Peregrine Lander which is then a payload
on the Ula Vulcan rocket the main rocket
that will take it to orbit and
eventually the moon physically iris is
complete
every mechanical thing every electronic
thing every little iota of the physical
parts are done iris is on board the
Lander iris is ready to go to the Moon
and what remains is to refine our
procedures our training our team that
will be operating the robot right here
from this room when it's on the moon
any Rover is risky business when it's
lean development without the big money
without the long duration without the
Aerospace infrastructure without the
deep deep experience it's even riskier
and something wonderful about working
with students is that their threshold
for risk is consistent with what had to
be to make Iris a reality
over 300 students almost 400 students
have participated in this since 2017.
the fact that it's students volunteering
their time or taking a class that they
get to have that impact is just
it's extraordinary
these students are going to be going out
and being the Next Generation in the
space industry and bringing this
experience to the next Rover or to the
next rocket to the next world that we go
to
they are the ones that have brought the
creativity the courage to drive the
indefatigable work
at the pursuit of Excellence that had
made it possible
[Music]